il ya eu des moments où c'était bien
cool au début et après et après ben avec
la pétole là et tout ça a été horrible
c'est bien dit si bien bagarré avec
aurélien justement et c'est dans les
phases de pétole le conte finalement il
a fini par me lâcher quoi à la dernière
pétole juste avant d'arriver ici du coup
j'avais un peu les boules mais sinon
dans l'ensemble ça va j'ai papeete
beaucoup de matos je fais du bain j'ai
vu péter un bras debout dehors j'ai gpli
un chandelier
voilà un dramatique j'ai un peu de mal
je t'assure mais des listes par contre
elles ont pris cher et voilà sinon c'est
de l'entretien courant va dire pour un
proto je suis même pas en fait à 8
chemin non ça 8 merci beaucoup c'est
cool c'est cool 8
c'est cool puisque
il y avait qu il ya charlot qui est
derrière et 667
moi alors c'est cool ouais content oui
si tu as quand même mieux sur la
deuxième parce que c'est la première
j'ai faso celle-là je n'étais pas dedans
tout de suite quoi enfin j'ai mis du
temps et après j'ai dû remonter des
places et ça a été ça a été assez
difficile comme c'est éprouvant va dire
le moral bas ça va non sans j j'ai pris
tous les moments nos radios compliquée
avec philosophie
j'écoutais de la musique
voilà je relisais les ici j'essaie de me
détendre comme je pouvais mais non non
ça peut être dramatique
voilà enfin la la place à laquelle je
termine n'est pas non plus dégueu donc
savoir ça me satisfait on va dire jamais
du top 10 donc je te dis voilà on va
essayer de faire mieux à la deuxième moi
j'avais plus totale j'avais les 40 lits
3 minimum plus un pack d'eau donc mais
reste un bidon de 20 litres complet
encore donc j'en ai pas utiliser tant
que ça sinon quoi d'autre la bouffe
j'avais pris pour 11 jours
donc c'est bon comme ça l'a fait j'ai
mangé mon dernier plat à en arriver